let's go next to our caller from the
eight five seven area code caller from
eight five seven tell us your name where
you're calling from and what's on your
mind today
hey what's up my name is Brody I'm
calling from Boston and I had some
questions about fraternities and how you
felt about them I never have been in a
fraternity I when I was at the
University of Massachusetts it was sort
of the fraternities were still there but
the entire frat area was ultimately
destroyed like every frat house was gone
and now in your head put in I don't
remember what it's never been a big
thing I went to rat parties and I went
to sorority parties and it was all fine
but it was nothing to write home about
really you know you think they have a
legitimate role in society given the
high profile deaths and other things and
sort of the aunt equation of maybe the
social networks due to you know the
internet I don't know how you define
whether it's a legitimate role I mean I
don't think they're necessary I think
there are all sorts of other community
groups available to college students
that when combined with the technology
the internet technologies for being in
touch with other people that now exist
sort of makes sororities and
fraternities irrelevant and the fact
that you know there have been hazing
deaths and all of this other stuff it's
just kind of like why I just it's hard
for me to imagine you know I thought I
regularly talk to high school students
who are going about to go into college
and the mere mention of looking into
maybe joining a sorority or a fraternity
I never hear it anymore and eight years
when I started speaking to high school
students I did so I think it's kind of
evaporating although I don't know if
membership is down nationally yeah I
went to a school with very little Greek
life but I really care about that and
now you know being out of college I
don't look back and regret for not being
part of a fraternity idea I just don't
care same here
I was in one but I don't know I'm
wondering if they have relevance in that
in modern college age yeah
fair question bro I might have to hear
from Boston College collars appreciate
that and very very interesting stuff